let f be a continuous function on the
closed interval from negative 2 to 1
where f of negative 2 is equal to 3 and
f of 1 is equal to 6 which of the
following is guaranteed by the
intermediate value theorem so before I
even look at this what do we know about
the intermediate value theorem well it
applies here it's a continuous function
on this closed interval we know what the
value of the function is at negative 2
it's 3 so let me write that F of
negative 2 is equal to 3 and F of 1 they
tell us right over here is equal to 6
and all the intermediate value theorem
tells us and if this is completely
unfamiliar to you I encourage you to
watch the video on the intermediate
value theorem is that if we have a
continuous function on some closed
interval then the function must take on
every value between the values at the
endpoints of the interval or another way
to say it is 4 for any L what between
between 3 & 6 3 & 6 there is at least
one C there is at least one 1 C 1 C
between or I could say 1 C in the
interval from negative 2 to 1 the closed
interval such that F of C is equal to L
this comes straight out of the
intermediate value theorem and just
saying it in everyday language is look
this is a continuous function actually
I'll draw it visually in a few seconds
but it makes sense that it is continuous
it's a if I were to draw the graph I
can't pick up my pencil well then it
makes sense that I would have to take on
every value between 3 & 6 or there's at
least one point in this interval where I
take on any given value between 3 & 6 so
let's see which of these answers are
consistent with that we only pick one so
f of C equal
tools for so that would be a case where
L is equal to four so if so there's at
least one C in this interval such that F
of C is equal to four we could say that
but that's not exactly what they're
saying here F of C could be four for at
least one C not in this interval
remember the C is our X this is our X
right over here so the C nu is going to
be in this interval I'll tell you I'll
take a look at it visually in a second
so that we can validate that we're not
saying for at least one C between three
and six F of C is equal to four we're
saying for at least one C in this
interval F then F of C is going to be
equal to four it's important that four
is between three and six because that's
the value of our function and the C
needs to be in our in our closed
interval along the x-axis so I'm going
to rule this out they're trying to
confuse us all right F of C equals zero
for at least one C between negative two
and one well here they got the interval
along the x-axis right that's where the
C would be between but it's not
guaranteed by the intermediate value
theorem that F of C is going to be equal
to zero because zero is not between
three and six so I'm going to rule that
one out I'm going to rule this one out
saying F of C equals zero and let's see
we're only left with this one so I hope
it works
so F of C is equal to 4 well that seems
reasonable because 4 is between 3 & 6
for at least one C between negative 2
and 1 well yeah because that's in this
interval right over here so I am feeling
good about that
and we could think about this visually
as well the intermediate value theorem
when you think about it visually makes a
lot of sense so let's let me draw the
x-axis first actually and then let me
draw my y-axis and I'm going to draw
them at different scales because my
y-axis well let's see if this is if this
is 6 this is 3 that's my y-axis this is
1 this is negative 1
this
is negative 2 and so we're continuous on
the closed interval from negative 2 to 1
and F of negative 2 is equal to 3 so let
me plot that F of negative 2 is equal to
3 so that's right over there and F of 1
is equal to 6 so that's right over there
and so let's try to draw a continuous
function so a continuous function it
includes these points and it's
continuous so the intuitive way to think
about is I can't pick up my pencil if
I'm drawing the graph of the function
which contains these two points so I
can't pick up my I can't do that that
would be picking up my pencil so it is a
continuous function so it takes on every
value as we can see it definitely does
that it takes on every value between 3 &
6 it might take on other values but we
know for sure and take on every value
between 3 & 6 and so wonder if we think
about 4 4 is right over here the way I
drew it it's actually looks like it's
almost taking on that value right at the
y-axis I forgot to label my x axis here
but you can see it took on that value in
for AC in this case between negative 2 &
1 and I could have drawn that graph
multiple different ways I could have
drawn it something like I could have
done it and actually it takes on there's
multiple times it takes on the value 4
here so this could be our C but once
again it's between the interval negative
2 & 1 this could be our C once again in
the interval between negative 2 & 1 or
this could be our C in between the
interval of negative 2 & 1 that's just
that way I happen to draw it I could
have drawn this thing is just a straight
line I could have drawn it like this and
then it looks like it's taking on for
only once and it's doing it right around
there this isn't necessarily true that
you take on you take on that you become
4 for at least one C between 3 & 6 3 & 6
aren't even on our graph here I would
have to go all the way to so 2 3 is 2 no
there's no guarantee that our function
that our function takes on for 4 1 C
between 3 & 6 we don't even know what
the function does when X is between 3
and six